you
it was a really terrific talk I think he
connected with everyone in the audience
those people who think about the innate
immune system those people who were
curious to hear a Nobel laureate speak
and those people who were really expert
in the particular field what do you
think of ER researchers in cancer
immunology or inflammation in cancer
well there's of course a tie-in between
cancer and inflammation that was another
way the whole story was approached
honestly I think this is one of the
greatest experience I've had talking to
a really establish and very successful
researcher I really like told dr. Boyer
talked about all of the past scientific
experiments that led up to his discovery
a key part of my story was the work of
Ricard Pfeiffer I think the audience got
a real sense of his trajectory his own
aha moments his own struggles and that
was inspirational because you get a
sense that really scientific research
and careers are built up step by step
I've read about dr. boilers work before
and I'm very interested in his area of
research but when you actually hear his
story about the events which led up to
those discoveries it changes your
perspective especially when he talks
about the evening where he discovered
the tlr4 September 5th 1998 I was in my
study at home looking anxiously at the
blast results and I saw a strong yet
unlike any I'd ever seen before
I think the students really appreciated
that to see someone who is a young
fairly unknown investigator in late 80s
and early 90s kind of risking everything
for your hunt that might not have worked
but that's the way great science is
often done it's really a rare
opportunity that they get to meet one on
one with someone like Bruce it was
really nice for a young scientist to be
able to see what exactly is required to
win a Nobel Prize
we were working really constantly week
after week and year after year to find
the mutation we very little rest of it I
like the fact that he mentioned like
perseverance is really important it was
not a kind of project where one could
work five days a week and eight hours a
day it's wonderful to see someone like
that a prominent scientist that has done
important work focused hard and was very
determined but not only has he
illuminated basic biology but he's also
been able to affect the lives of many
people who are suffering from diseases
loose burglars work is seminal for
immunity and in genetics as well these
are all concepts these are all tools
that we work with and help us understand
the systems that we are trying to
manipulate in order to treat and cure
disease
this organization is driven by science
and to get a chance to meet with you
know some of the brightest scientists in
the world is always an exciting time
after the formal part of a session the
group of scientists just bundled around
Bruce and started bombarding him with
really tough questions science is about
interactions you learn and teach and
that's how you develop your knowledge
that's how you turn ideas into better
ideas and eventually medicines I'm
inspired I'm excited and you know
hearing his story sometimes gives you
just the reason to get the next day to
work and and try to develop a drug and
do some time difficulties covers
you